the first episode starts with Simone
Anderson running to school late for her
exams Simone's friends are waiting for
her in the classroom and their group is
up next the teacher warns them that if
they take any longer than 2 minutes they
will be kicked out of the exam just in
time Simone arrives in the classroom
saving the assignment however before
they can enter the exam Hall Simon's
father Frederick Anderson comes running
in and interrupts the group of friends
Simone is confused by her father's
anxious Behavior as he grabs her arm and
tells her they have to leave immediately
medely Simone is surprised and explains
that she has exams to finish but her
father tells her that it's an emergency
Frederick instructs Simone's friends to
go home and stay inside he reveals that
Simone's brother Rasmus and her mother
are waiting for her in the car he warns
his daughter that they must leave before
the rain starts once they are in the car
Simone demands an explanation however
Frederick is on the phone with someone
named Sten and is not paying attention
to her he tells Sten that they will be
there soon without providing details
Simon's mother takes the phone away from
Frederick because they are driving
dangerously fast on the highway
meanwhile the radio announces that
people in the Ving Borg area are
developing respiratory problems after
the heavy rainfall Simone looks at the
back window and sees dark rain clouds
approaching quickly Rasmus gets Restless
in the back seat and unbuckles his seat
belt in response his mother scolds him
to put it back on in the ensuing
confusion they get into a car accident
and narrowly avoid serious injuries a
van driver comes up to them and checks
if everything is okay in instead of
answering Frederick yells at him to move
his truck out of the way or else all of
them would die due to the Rain realizing
they cannot continue driving due to the
traffic jam the Anderson family abandons
their car and heads for the forest on
foot just as they are about to enter the
forest Simone turns back and sees the
van driver looking at them suspiciously
once they are deep in the Forest
Frederick takes the charge and urges
everyone to run faster after a while
they reach a mysterious safe house with
the name of poen written over it Rasmus
recognizes the name of poen is his
father works for the company to
everyone's surprise Frederick opens the
door using his fingerprints and urges
everyone to go inside quickly as the
rain is about to start inside the safe
house they enter a disinfecting chamber
and descend into a bunker Frederick
explains that aalen built these shelters
for emergencies and in here they have
everything needed to survive he then
hands his wife an electronic manual for
the bunker and says that he has to leave
immediately confused by the rapid turn
of events the kids follow their mother
to the kitchen however Frederick pulls
Simon aside and reveals that there is a
deadly virus in the rain and that the
situation is much worse than she could
imagine he warns her that nobody should
ever find Rasmus because he is the key
to the problem after entrusting Simone
with her younger brother's safety
Frederick leaves through a tunnel
without any further explanation as they
attempt to make sense of the events
Simone watches videos on her phone
showing chaotic scenes in Ving Borg
people are terrified and pleading for
help on social media meanwhile Rasmus
struggles to adjust to the bunker and
demands answers from his mother in
response their mother makes them hot
chocolate thinking that would calm her
young son suddenly they hear loud
banging noises from the upstairs door
Simon assumes it is their father and
urges her mother to open the door
however her mother dismisses the request
assuring Simon that he knows the entry
code but before she can stop them the
kids rush out and open the bunker door
it is raining hard outside and the van
driver they met earlier stands at the
door screaming in agony he grabs Rasmus
by his shirt and tries to pull himself
inside fortunately their mother lunges
at the driver rescuing Rasmus however
both the mother and the driver are
horrifically killed as the rain
mercilessly falls on them with no choice
the kids close the bunker door and go
inside Simone devastated by her mother's
death is determined to reach her father
however communication is crippled the
mobile network is down and the
electronic Communication System between
the apoll and bunkers has failed as they
explore the bunker searching for a way
to contact their father the children
stumble upon a radio with renewed hope
they switch it on on and to their
surprise they managed to connect with
someone named Phillip Philip informs
them of a hospital near Ving BG where a
pickup Center has been established
furthermore Simon requests Philip to try
contacting her father over the landline
and inform her of any updates the next
time he calls Simone however can't
muster the courage to leave the bunker
and visit the hospital her father's
words urging her to protect her brother
Echoes In Her Mind a flashback scene
transports her to a hospital room where
Rasmus lies critically ill his parents
grapple with a difficult decision
Frederick fears the risks of using a
potent but untested treatment on his son
while his wife insists it is the only
way to save their son overcome by her
protective instincts Simone abandons her
plan to venture outside instead she
reaffirms her commitment to stay inside
and Safeguard her brother with renewed
Vigor she cheers him up with Lively
dances and engages him in indoor
gardening determined to become
self-reliant she Masters the act of
changing the air purification filter
enabling her to manage the bunker
independently the next scene takes us 5
years in the future where Rasmus is no
longer a small kid however his longing
for the outside world remains unchanged
meanwhile Simone faced a harsh reality
Their Food Supplies are dwindling making
an inevitable escape from the bunker
their only option later that night she
Dawn her protective suit and Ventures
into the unknown leaving Rasmus asleep
in the safety of their bunker emerging
from the bunker Simone tries to locate
her mother's remains as she died right
outside the door instead she is greeted
by an overround forest and a gentle deer
her path leads her to the supposed
pickup point at the hospital but instead
of a hopeful Gathering of people she is
confronted with the Grim sight of
decaying dead bodies a chilling memory
resurfaces as she has a flashback an
intense debate between her parents her
father driven by an unwavering belief in
his ability to save countless lives
advocates for releasing a virus capable
of eradicating multi-resistant bacteria
her mother however cautions against the
unknown consequences of such an act
despite her warnings her father remained
Resolute in his conviction when the
flashback ends she finds no living soul
in the hospital except a dog that chases
her Simone rushes back to the bunker
just as Rasmus wakes up after learning
of her fruitless search outside they
make a decision to venture out together
the following day however their plans
are disrupted overnight when the
Bunker's air vents become blocked
causing oxygen levels to plummet
Dangerously In A desperate act to save
Simon from Suffocation a disoriented
Rasmus drags her out of the bun without
any protective gear before they can
catch a breather in the open the
siblings are swiftly surrounded by five
suited individuals in the final scene of
the first episode we see the leader of
the mysterious group brandishing a Gun
menacingly Orders the brother and sister
to go back into the bunker episode two
Stay Together begins with a scene inside
an army truck transporting a group of
soldiers on their way to patrol the
streets the truck arrives at the bridge
marking the boundary between the
infected and non-infected zones those
who have been exposed to the Rain are or
infected individuals without undergoing
quarantine are prohibited from crossing
the safety line the commander issues a
strict order use deadly force if anyone
disobeys they drop off a lone soldier
Martin who is assigned to the first
shift back at the bunker the masked men
lock Simone and Rasmus in a room and
scour the bunker for food Simone
protests that they are not infected and
have been isolated in the bunker for 6
years but the leader counters that he
saw her in town finding nothing of value
the group prepares to depart however
Simone captures the leader's attention
by revealing the Bunker's electronic
manual which contains a map of other
similar bunkers she shatters the manual
forcing the leader to take them along in
the meantime on the bridge Martin spots
a woman approaching with a baby in her
arms he sternly orders her to Halt and
fires a warning shot however overcome
with emotion he is unable to pull the
trigger even as she crosses the safety
line his nightmare comes true as a
distress call from his Command Center
soon follows upon reaching the scene
Martin finds all his fellow soldiers
dead except for the one who had made the
call helplessly Martin watches as the
remaining Soldier succumbs to a painful
death having earlier touched the
infected baby with his entire unit wiped
out Martin flees in Terror meanwhile
Guided by Simone and Rasmus the bunker
group Matt beatric Jean Patrick and Lee
sets out in search of another bunker for
food despite their General mistrust of
the siblings beatric strikes up a
conversation with Rasmus as they walk
along the road suddenly a vehicle
screeches to a halt nearby and two m men
in army gear emerge the group scrambles
for cover under a sheet of aluminum
explained by beatric to be a shield
against heat seeking drones used to
capture and torture survivors the Drone
fails to detect them but spots another
woman fleeing nearby beatric pleads with
the group to rescue the woman and they
reluctantly give Chase however before
anyone can reach her the woman plunges
into a stream contaminated with a dead
animal in a grin display of this world's
harsh realities Martin shoots and kills
both the masked men and the woman
Patrick retriev leaves the Drone now
folded inside a ball likee shell from
one of the Dead masked men later that
night the group finds refuge in an
abandoned School the stark contrast
between the siblings and the rest of the
group becomes evident when Rasmus
struggles to wear boots from a dead body
a task the others have grown accustomed
to Patrick upon seeing rasmus's drawings
mocks him and expresses disbelief that
the siblings could have survived
underground for 6 years deep into the
night Rasmus inadvertently Witnesses
beatric and Martin engaged in an
intimate moment the next day Rasmus
tries to avoid beatric who attempts to
engage him in conversation they keep on
walking searching for the next bunker in
an unfortunate turn of events Rasmus
accidentally steps on water with
absolutely no hesitation Martin raises
his gun ready to shoot him however
Simone intervenes asking beatric to
check if rasmus's boots are leaking
beatric confirms that rasmus's foot is
dry preventing Martin from pulling the
trigger finally the group stumbles upon
a bunker and intrigued Martin observes
Simone unlocking the door using her
fingerprints inside as others indulge in
eating the ration stored in the bunker
she discovers her father's mobile phone
containing a video message from his
former boss the second episode ends as
Simone plays the video message for
Rasmus the message urges Frederick to
proceed to aalen's Main Headquarters in
Sweden at any cost as he is the only
individual capable of halting the
catastrophe the third episode titled
avoid the city begins with a flashback
scene beatric Lee and Jee are
desperately fleeing from two men Martin
and Patrick Patrick urges Martin to
eliminate the three strangers and simply
sees their belongings however Martin
lowers his weapon when beatric assures
him that she can lead him to food back
in the present Simone presents Martin
with the video message discovered on her
father's phone she attempts to persuade
him to accompany her to Sweden where
they might encounter her father Martin
swiftly rejects this notion having
previously encountered numerous false
claims of safe havens the only remaining
route from Denmark to Sweden is via the
long bridge in Copenhagen any survivors
encountered along the way would readily
kill them for food Martin instructs them
to follow the train tracks and avoid
strangers before allowing the siblings
to depart for Sweden a few hours later
upon learning of the siblings departure
for Sweden Lee and beatric realized that
they are doomed without assistance
driven by her compassionate nature Lee
insists on helping the siblings
recalling their previous acts of
kindness determined to Aid the
vulnerable Duo Lee beatric and Jean
follow them eventually catching up with
the siblings in the desolate City Center
Patrick and Matt remain in the bunker
with Matt attempting to mask his
distress over Beatrice's departure as he
grapples with the reasons behind her
decision the scene shifts to a flashback
beatric and her two companions escort
Martin and Patrick to the greenhouse
where Jean prepares a meal for them
following a brief exchange of
conversation the group settles for the
night in the greenhouse later under the
cloak of Darkness beatric engages in an
intimate affair with Martin in the
present day after a period of
deliberation Martin decides to pursue be
and the rest of the group much to
Patrick's disappointment Martin's
decision clearly indicates his feelings
for beatric meanwhile in the city center
the group takes refuge in an abandoned
Burger King to eat their rationed lunch
that they packed from the bunker Lee and
jeene temporarily excused themselves to
find a new pair of glasses for Jean to
improve his vision however the situation
takes a turn for the worse as a group of
starving survivors stumbles upon the
group while they are enjoying their meal
Simone Rasmus and beatric run in a
desperate attempt to escape resulting in
their division into smaller groups
outside ominous rainclouds gather
rapidly beatric and Rasmus seek refuge
in a bungalow nearby separated from the
rest of the group beatric tells Rasmus
that she has a deeply guarded secret she
discloses that this was her childhood
home where she was born and raised
recalling the tumultuous divorce between
her parents she admits leaving home to
escape the emotional turmoil and going
to a movie to forget the problems at
home Upon returning she found the world
transformed by the devastating rain her
father had left her three separate
messages first reporting her mother's
death the second reporting his own
rapidly deteriorating health and the
third message was simply empty ever
since she has never looked back
meanwhile Martin and Patrick also make
their way to the city center they are
hiding in a wreckage of an overturned
bus waiting for the rain to subside
Patrick still has the Drone shell he
acquired from the two soldiers in the
forest after being unable to make it
work he tosses the shell onto the ground
in a fit of frustration yet unexpectedly
a map projects from the shell they
notice a bold red line on one edge of
the map depicting a wall that separates
two parts of the city Martin realizes
that this wall separates the quarantine
Zone where all the infected people are
from the safe Zone where the healthy
people live meanwhile alone and
separated from the rest of the group
Simon seeks shelter in an abandoned
building with a young boy she found on
the street upon discovering him taking
morphine pills she offers him a packet
of food from the bunker his father
expresses his gratitude and reveals
their intention to cross the the bridge
to seek medical attention for their son
in a place called little Bard inspired
by this news Simone decides to venture
out once the rain subsides however her
act of kindness does not go unnoticed
the packet of food attracts the
attention of The Starving survivors who
Trail her before Simone can alert her
friends who are waiting for her at the
Burger King a ravenous but uninfected
man follows her back to the group he
seizes Rasmus and brandishes a knife
threatening to harm him if they don't
surrender their food Simone frantically
instructs Jee to hand over his food
rations In the Heat of the Moment she
accidentally reveals the existence of
another bunker with an abundance of food
the man driven by desperation demands to
know more about this bunker suddenly
Martin appears on the scene and
threatens to shoot the man unless he
releases Rasmus however the man plunges
a knife into rasmus's abdomen and flees
with the food leaving the group in a
State of Shock the group put Rasmus in a
shopping cart and run towards the nearby
bunker however they find that the bunker
has been broken in and ransacked they
lay down down Rasmus on the bed and wrap
the wound with duck tape beatric
volunteers to look after him allowing
Simone to rest with Rasmus Gravely
injured the group hastily transports him
in a shopping cart towards the nearby
bunker however upon reaching the bunker
they discover it has been ransacked and
left in Ruins they gently place Rasmus
on a bed and hastily bandage his wound
with duck tape recognizing the need for
rest beatric volunteers to care for
Rasmus allowing Simon to take a much
needed break in a flashback scene we are
transported to the early days of beatric
and Martin's encounter the day after
their shared dinner Martin suggests that
it might be best for them to part ways
however beatris reveals a deeply buried
secret gesturing towards a small house
near the road she discloses that it was
her childhood home where she witnessed
the tragic demise of her parents and
younger sister in the aftermath of the
rain catastrophe since that fateful day
she has never dared to enter the house
beatric urges Martin to include her and
her companions in his journey
emphasizing the strength and protection
that come with traveling together rather
than venturing alone the third episode
concludes with Simone and Martin huddled
in the bunker deliberating their next
move Simone informs him of the supposed
existence of a doctor in Little Beard
accessible through a Bridge Crossing
meanwhile Martin reveals the holographic
map they acquired revealing a walled off
area encompassing a portion of Denmark
he speculates that this region serves as
a quarantine Zone and Beyond its borders
the population has been spared from the
Affliction with this newfound
information Martin proposes their
Journey towards this uninfected
territory